Trascrizione: Martina Giambattista
Revisore: Michela Pezzarini
Ciao a tutti io sono Angelo Maggi.
Attore, doppiatore,
direttore del doppiaggio italiano.
Attore, soprattutto.
Ma è un mestiere essere attori?
Sì, in fondo lo è.
Mi ha fatto ricco.
Non in quanto che vi ho guadagnato,
anche se ho guadagnato.
Ma per quello che mi ha fatto risparmiare.
Cominciamo a elencare:
spese mediche, psichiatriche,
scolastiche, turistiche, spese voluttuarie
e prima o poi funerarie, insomma,
spese varie di cui il mestiere
dell’attore ha sostenuto l’onere.
In pratica dal futile al serio
più segreto insostenibile,
da Dio a Bacco, più tabacco, e Venere,
tutto è stato pagato, computerizzato,
scontato da una certa accezione di teatro
che, una volta inghiottita
per intero la mia vita,
ne ha... assorbito.
Il come non lo so.
Motivazione ed amministrazione
nei suoi particolari borderò.
Cominciava così, con questo monologo,
lo spettacolo ‘Fa male il teatro’,
che mi vide debuttare
la bellezza di 42 anni fa,
e da allora ho fatto tantissimo teatro
con i più grandi,
ho debuttato con il mio maestro
Vittorio Gassman
ma poi ho avuto la fortuna
di lavorare con Albertazzi, Calenda,
Caprioli, Mario Carotenuto, Squarzina.
Poi ho fondato una mia compagnia,
‘I Bugiardi’,
con cui ho fatto tanti spettacoli,
e poi sono approdato al doppiaggio.
Quando?
Sono approdato al doppiaggio
nel lontano 1982.
Doppiavo me stesso,
perché così capita,
si scopre il doppiaggio
quando doppi te stesso,
come succedeva una volta,
che la presa diretta
non era così buona come oggi.
Doppiai me stesso
nel film ‘Sapore di mare’,
nel primo ‘Sapore di mare’.
E che cosa successe? Una magia.
Io entrai in questa sala di doppiaggio
e mi colpì soprattutto il buio.
Sì, il buio.
La voce oltre il buio
di questi attori straordinari,
magari miei coetanei,
e io mi dicevo,
‘‘Mamma mia come sono bravi’’,
″io non potrei mai
essere bravo come loro.”
E poi soltanto in un secondo momento
ho capito che erano dotati
di una grandissima tecnica,
allora a me completamente sconosciuta.
Poi con gli anni ho seguito una grande
direttrice dell’epoca, Fede Arnaud,
e ho doppiato i miei primi protagonisti:
Hugh Grant in ‘Notting Hill’,
Bruce Willis in ‘Sesto senso’,
e finalmente Tom Hanks, la mia prima volta
con Tom Hanks nel film ‘Cast Away’.
A chi mi chiede se preferisco tra le
forme di espressione di un attore
tra il teatro, il cinema,
il doppiaggio, la radio,
tutto quello che io ho frequentato,
io dico che il teatro è la mia vita,
non l’ho mai abbandonato
e continuo a farlo, assolutamente,
ma il doppiaggio forse
è quella che preferisco
perché la reputo, tra le forme espressive
dell’attore, la più meritocratica,
perché se hai talento
prima o poi devi eccellere.
E poi perché ti permette
di confrontarti con questi grandi attori
che hai la fortuna, che io ho la fortuna,
di doppiare da tanti anni,
come Tom Hanks per esempio,
che ti permette di arricchirti come uomo,
ma anche come professionista, come attore.
Alle persone che sostengono
che un doppiatore è un attore a metà,
ecco io rispondo parafrasando
‘Il visconte’ di Italo Calvino
che non mi sento affatto
un attore dimezzato,
bensì io mi sento un attore raddoppiato
io mi sento un ″doppiattore″.
Ci ho fatto uno spettacolo perché
sentivo l’urgenza di raccontare questo:
che il doppiatore non è un mestiere,
ma è una skill del mestiere dell’attore.
Cosa deve avere un doppiatore
di vaglia per eccellere?
Intanto deve essere poco riconoscibile,
deve avere una grande capacità mimetica
Deve essere un camaleonte.
Deve avere un grande orecchio,
anche musicale.
Un doppiatore per eccellere alla fine
deve essere rigore e sregolatezza.
La sregolatezza per l’unicità
che si deve dare all’interpretazione
che si fa doppiando quell’attore.
Il rigore per la tecnica.
La tecnica del mestiere dell’attore.
Quando mi sono laureato in biologia
ho scoperto che esiste un doppiare
anche in zootecnia, pensate.
Riferito ad un agnello,
doppiare un agnello
quando la mamma, la pecora non ha latte
a sufficienza per nutrire questo agnello
e quindi questo agnello
viene dato per essere nutrito
a una seconda madre che lo nutrirà.
Ecco, non vi sembra un po’ la stessa cosa
che avviene nel doppiaggio di un attore?
Un personaggio nutrito di emozioni
da quell’attore una prima volta
viene successivamente nutrito
una seconda volta di altre emozioni,
quelle del suo doppiatore,
attore, interprete italiano.
Ecco, questo è il doppiaggio.
Una domanda
che mi viene rivolta molto spesso:
se ho conosciuto personalmente
gli attori che comunemente doppio.
In genere io rispondo
che non tutti hanno avuto
il privilegio di conoscermi.
Vabbè sto scherzando ovviamente,
non è facile
che tutte queste grandi star americane
possano incontrarti.
Io però ho avuto la fortuna
di incontrare, di conoscere
forse l’attore che ho più volte doppiato,
che ho avuto la fortuna
di doppiare più volte,
che è Tom Hanks.
Ci siamo conosciuti a Venezia
una quindicina d’anni fa,
veniva presentato fuori concorso
il film ‘The Terminal’
In cui per la prima volta
lui interpreta uno straniero,
un cittadino della Krakozhia.
Krakozhia, e lui è Viktor Navorski,
Stato immaginario, vicino Bulgaria,
quindi anch’io parla in questo modo
con il consulente in sala di doppiaggio,
consulente bulgaro, Vincent Luharo.
Lui rimane bloccato in aeroporto,
in terminal per uno anno,
e lui poi impara lingua
e anche io
ho fatto in italiano miglioramenti
dopo studiare lingua inglese, io italiano.
E lui innamora di Catherine Zeta Jones
Mangia boccone, mangia boccone,
bocca mangione.
Ho avuto anche io
il consulente con cui parlare
cosa che avviene durante il doppiaggio
in cui si parlano delle
lingue diverse dall’italiano,
o comunque delle inflessioni,
abbiamo dei consulenti.
Quindi dopo la proiezione del film
sono stato presentato a lui
dai distributori della Universal Italia
come la sua voce italiana
per i film che lui faceva
con la DreamWorks,
del suo amico Steven Spielberg,
che era presente anche lui a Venezia
e ho conosciuto anche lui,
il grande Steven Spielberg.
E così insomma siamo stati presentati,
sono Angelo Maggi, la tua voce italiana
dei film con la DreamWorks,
quindi io ti prego Tom, cerca di lavorare
sempre con la DreamWorks
così lavori tu e lavoro pure io.
Diciamo che ho tirato acqua al mio mulino,
ma poi in realtà l’ho doppiato
tantissime altre volte,
in più di 25, 30 film,
adesso non ricordo neanche più.
E i film della DreamWorks
erano tra l’altro anche altri
‘The post’ per esempio,
‘Il Ponte delle Spie’, film straordinario
sulla Guerra Fredda, anni ’60
in cui tra l’altro successe questo,
durante il film dei delinquenti
gli rubano il cappotto
e lui nella Berlino gelata
in pieno inverno si prende una bronchite.
E quindi da metà film in poi
Tom Hanks parla
con voce raffreddata, un po’ nasale.
(Colpo di tosse)
Insomma,
(Starnuto)
tutto quello che ha a che fare
con un raffreddore, una bronchite.
Che succede in quei casi
in sala di doppiaggio?
In quel caso è intervenuto,
per quanto mi riguarda, l’effetto eccì.
No? Avete capito tutti naturalmente.
A metà film più o meno
anch’io mi sono preso una bronchite.
Quindi è successo che tutti questi versi
sono venuti particolarmente veri,
bene insomma,
tanto che la supervisor americana
della Dreamworks Claudia Guirzman
ha scelto tutti i miei versi
per le edizioni europee del film.
Se voi andate per esempio a Parigi
e vedete alla tele  ‘Il ponte delle spie’,
vedrete che Tom Hanks parla
ovviamente doppiato in francese
(Parlata francese)
(Colpo di tosse)
È mio.
La stessa cosa se andate in Germania
a Berlino e vedete ‘Il ponte delle spie’
Tom Hanks parlerà doppiato in tedesco.
(Parlata tedesca)
(Colpo di tosse)
È sempre mio.
Insomma, sembra una boutade invece
è quello che è successo veramente,
quindi capitano queste cose un po’ strane.
Anche questo è il doppiaggio.
Ma come si fa a creare una voce
di un cartone animato?
Questo è interessante.
Mentre nel doppiaggio
di un attore in carne e ossa
dobbiamo seguire sempre molto l’originale,
ascoltare in cuffia l’originale e quindi
e quindi avvicinare molto il timbro,
sempre come vi dicevo,
quasi alla più vicinanza
possibile al timbro vocale
dell’attore che stiamo doppiando,
quindi incartapecorirsi, dico io,
nell’attore che doppiamo,
quindi essere molto vicini.
Nel cartone animato
è un po’ più libera la cosa.
Ascoltiamo quello che è stato fatto
dall’attore in precedenza,
però siamo più liberi di creare
e di inventare una voce.
È un po’ quello che è successo a me
con Woody di ‘Toy Story 4’,
l’eredità che ho avuto da Fabrizio Frizzi,
è stato più facile perché la voce
originaria era quella di Tom Hanks
ma con il commissario Winchester,
il commissario dei Simpson,
che doppio ormai da 33 anni,
quindi ormai è una vita,
Come è stata creata questa voce?
Un po’ doveva essere napoletana
e quindi io ho pescato nella mia
memoria emotiva da mio nonno Angelo,
che era un napoletano della Vicarìa,
normalissimo insomma.
Però abituato io
a crescere con mio nonno
(Parlata napoletana)
ho avuto sempre nelle orecchie
questa parlata napoletana di mio nonno
ma soprattutto poi ho avuto
un input importante da un mio maestro
che ho avuto alla Bottega Teatrale
che ho fatto a Firenze,
la Bottega Teatrale di Vittorio Gassman,
il grande Eduardo De Filippo
che ho avuto come insegnante,
ho avuto la fortuna
di avere come insegnante.
Eduardo De Filippo,
sì ma lui non potevi chiamarlo
Signor De Filippo, Eduardo De Filippo,
lui era Eduardo.
Perché tu andavi:
“Scusi signor De Filippo”
″Che signor De Filippo, c’ho messo
50 anni ad essere Eduardo solamente″
si capisce che sarebbe stata una voce
per un commissario un poco magro
una voce con le fossette, si capisce,
te piace ’u presepe?
E invece no.
Il commissario è un po’ paffutello,
un po’ cicciottello, quindi
ho fatto un miscuglio tra mio nonno,
Eduardo, mio nonno, Eduardo,
mio nonno, Eduardo,
ci ho dato una spruzzata di grasso.
La voce del commissario Winchester,
un poco chiatta,
sentite com’è chiatta adesso?
E invece questa è una voce magra,
napoletana magra.
E questa invece è una voce chiatta,
lo sentite com’è chiatta?
Come si fa? Si butta
e si incicciottisce la voce,
si diventa un po’ chiatti e bassi
e si diventa  Winchester,
il commissario dei Simpson.
Così.
Tutti vogliono un lieto fine.
Ma le cose non vanno sempre così.
Forse stavolta.
Spero che se ascolterete questo messaggio
sia per festeggiare.
Spero che le famiglie siano riunite,
che sia ristabilita qualcosa che somiglia
a una versione normale del pianeta.
Sempre che sia mai esistita.
Che mondo meraviglioso, che universo.
Se mi avessero detto dieci anni fa
che non eravamo soli,
di altre forme di vita
figuriamoci, non sarei rimasto sorpreso.
Chi si immaginava le forze epiche
dell’oscurità e della luce
che entrano in gioco.
Nel bene e nel male,
questa è la realtà in cui Morgan
dovrà trovare il modo per crescere.
E così ho pensato
di registrare un salutino.
In caso di una prematura dipartita.
La mia intendo.
Insomma non che la morte
sia sempre prematura.
Il viaggio nel tempo
che tenteremo di fare domani
mi sta facendo perdere il sonno
con questo fatto della sopravvivenza.
Ma il compito dell'eroe è questo.
Una parte del viaggio è la fine.
Ma perché questo trip?
Tutto quanto andrà esattamente
come deve andare.
Vi amo 3000.
Ciao!